what's up guys Alan dragu here and in
today's video I'm going to give you
three copyrighting triggers that almost
feel unethical to help you triple your
Sal so let's Dive Right In actually
before we dive in could you and would
you please hit the like and the
Subscribe button it lets me know that
you find a ton of value from these
videos and that you want me to keep
making them for you for free so please
do that real quick and let's jump right
in the first tactic is a deadline this
is one of the most powerful tactics that
you can use when you're selling anything
and there's a couple ways to use a
deadline one of the most common ways
that I see people using a deadline and
that I've personally used is a
time-based discount okay say you sell a
thing a jig for $200 well for the next 3
days it's on sale for $99 okay so you
have a 50% off discount for 3 days only
okay 3 days only being the key they have
to have a deadline because if people
don't have a deadline they don't
actually have a reason to move today
right and if they don't have a reason to
move today humans are naturally a little
bit on the lazier side so they're just
not going to move at all right they're
not going to take any action so you want
to encourage people to take action now
so a time-based discount is a fantastic
way to do that the second way to manage
a deadline or to use a deadline in your
copyrighting is to do a time-based price
increase this is actually my personal
favorite okay and it and it's the
reverse side so say you have a course
that you're selling for $99 well on
Monday in 2 days from now the price goes
up to $199 so you're actually going to
increase the price by 50% okay and so in
that in that sort of manner you're
giving people a deadline to move now and
get it out of bargain before the value
goes up the reason I like this one is
because it actually makes the product
more valuable and so it seems like
people are getting a bargain right which
they are especially if you're going to
be honest about this and do the price
increase which I guess I should say be
honest about if you're going to do this
be honest if you're going to do a a 3day
deadline then cut it off at three days
if you're going to do a price increase
on Monday you better increase the price
on Monday right don't be a sleazy
marketer and the third way of doing a
deadline is a Time based bonus okay for
the next s days only when you buy this
thing on a jig you also get this thing
I'm a jig now the key to this is that
the bonus has to be valuable in itself
you can't say I'm going to sell you this
course and also you get this little book
thing that's five bucks and it's trash
like it's more powerful if the bonus
that you give in itself would have had
to be purchased on its own so if I do
this course you also get my other course
for free which I sell for $99 so it
actually looks like you get this $200
course and you get this $100 course but
you're only paying for the $200 course
that's a big bonus right so that that
value is like wow that's incredible and
again you put a deadline on it to help
people move quickly moving on to
copyrighting trigger number two and that
is scarcity scarcity increases demand
meaning the fewer that you have and the
hungrier that people are for the thing
that you have the more demand that you
have for it and honestly the more you
could charge for it and two of the best
ways to do scarcity are limited spots or
limited uh Goods right so actually it's
the same thing but in two different
manners right so limited spots could be
something that you're hosting for a
webinar a workshop a conference and
whatever you're doing right where you
say hey I'm hosting a live webinar but
I'm only doing it for 10 people okay so
the first 10 people to sign up what this
actually allows you to do is increase
your price okay especially if you're
doing something very Niche and so you
can do a live webinar in this hypers
specific Niche and what you would have
been able to charge is $200 but now you
could charge $3.99
because you have very limited spots and
it helps people move the other thing you
could do is combine scarcity with a
deadline so now you have 10 spots
limited for this webinar that you're
doing and registration closes in 3 days
and you can buy it right now for this
price right but tomorrow the price goes
up you see what I just did there I just
combined all I just combined scarcity
and a deadline with a Time based
increase okay so registration closes
that's a deadline price goes up tomorrow
that's another deadline and there's only
limited spots now I'm now I'm itching
like you're almost unable to not click
by if you're very interested in that
thing until I pair it up with number
three is risk removal okay the number
one thing that you need to do at the
very end of this okay you got the
deadline you got the scarcity if you're
using both those and stacking those you
need to remove the risk because what
those two things did is they added
pressure okay scarcity is pressure to
move fast and a deadline is pressure to
move fast you need to remove the
pressure to make somebody at ease to be
able to purchase you a thing but excited
and the way that you do that is by
removing risk and there's a couple ways
to remove risk here's a common one is
like a 30-day money back guarantee hey
if you jump into my webinar and for
whatever reason you didn't get all the
benefits that I said you would get out
of this webinar within 30 days if you
reach out to me I'll give you your money
back no problem that's a risk removal
that literally means no risk it means I
could pay the $2.99 now or the $3.99 now
and if I don't feel like it was worth
that this guy's going to give me my
money back that's an important factor
that helps people move quicker they're
now at ease so it's a no-brainer it's a
deadline I'm getting the discount and if
it doesn't work out I get my money back
it's it's almost impossible not to click
that here's a variation of that money
back guarantee made famous by Frank ker
when he wrote a sales letter uh to
attract clients for his client work he
actually did a money back guarantee and
promised that he would give money on top
of the money back guarantee if it didn't
work out I.E if I don't deliver what I
say I'm going to deliver not only am I
going to give you your money back I'm
going to slap a couple hundred bucks on
top of your money back so you actually
profit from our time together now that
is a very courageous and insane money
back guarantee huge for risk removal I
mean literally the worst case scenario
is somebody does the thing you want them
to do they get their money back and they
make extra money if you don't deliver
the results now this is very bold and
you have to have an incredible product
an incredible offer to make sure that
you're not handing a bunch of dollars
back and losing a bunch of money right
you have to be very confident to do that
but how could you as a human not click
that and buy that with that kind of risk
removal which leads me to the last form
of risk removal and one of my personal
favorites especially if you're getting
into the copyrighting scene right now
and I call it the 100% commission risk
removal okay so when I was getting my
foot in the door and trying to just pick
up some client work and and get people
to say yes I was taking 100% commission
deals okay so I would reach out to a
client and I would say hey I do your
welcome sequence for you right I would
write these emails in a welcome sequence
for you and I will take uh I will take
100% of my pay as commission meaning if
I increase your sales by x amount I get
a piece of that and if I don't increase
your sales I don't get any of that so
it's literally no risk for that client
it's no risk for that person to take my
offer it's very irresistible to say yes
to that you have to say yes you have to
jump in and so that's a very great
tactic to get under your skin now again
you have to have a good product you have
to deliver results cuz at the end of the
day you could not be getting paid but
that is going to help you focus more and
deliver a very good product as well as
increase your sales so that's it those
are the three copyrighting triggers that
almost feel unethical but they are not
especially if you have a very fantastic
product that you can deliver your
promise on so to Quick recap a deadline
scarcity and risk removal if you dive
into those three I guarantee you triple
your sales guarantee it and if you don't
you can reach out to me and I will give
you every dollar that you spent back on
this video all right that's it that
wraps this up go ahead wait around for a
second because there's going to be more
videos that you can go down the rabbit
hole of all my content and learn tons of
copyrighting stuff so again I appreciate
you so much thank you for being here
I'll catch you on the next one oh this
is so good I freaking love coffee in
fact actually one of my dream clients
would be to work with a coffee company
you know what if you are a coffee
company and you want me to Triple your
email Revenue well then if you sign up
to my services in the next two days I
only have one spot left I guarantee that
I will take 100% commission deal on the
increased Revenue that I get your emails
guarantee it can't wait let's work
together